hello and welcome to a very special live
interview of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constantine kissen and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant uh guest today returns for
the h hundredth time he's a political
expert Mt Goodwin welcome back to
trigonometry thanks for having me we're
family now we are uh you're here as I
said not for the first time so don't
need much of an introduction you are our
go-to man for political analysis
particularly here in the UK about
everything that's going on and it has
been rather an eventful couple of days
hasn't it Matt what have you made of
everything that's happened over the last
weekend and in the last two days as well
we're witnessing the disintegration of
the conservative party we're witnessing
a party that no longer knows what it is
what it's about uh how to connect with
the country the departure of sella
bravman her resignation letter which you
will have seen this afternoon to Rishi
sunak which didn't pull any punches just
putting it mildly I mean it was brutal
what what this what this says to me look
is is You' got a party that was handed a
unique historic opportunity in 2019 the
big realignment we talked about it on
this show the day after the election I
remember that conversation very funly
and we said at the time for the
conservative party to hold this
political realignment it's got to
deliver for workingclass voters for
older voters for cultural conservatives
it's got to be what it says on the tin
now fast forward and here we are we have
a conservative party that is basically
retreating to the David Cameron liberal
Cameroon tradition social liberalism
cultural liberalism which doesn't really
know what it is and I think soel Bran's
um departure and David Cameron's return
to Frontline politics really symbolizes
this existential crisis for the
conservative party so what we're heading
into now for the next 12 months what
we're heading into is an ideological
philosophical Civil War for the for the
soul of conservatism and that is going
to determine not just what kind of
conservative party we have but what kind
of country we have over the next 10 20
years that's a great overview of the of
the next 12 months and obviously it's a
pivotal moment I think in the history of
this country I think there's no argument
about that can we take a moment though
to go back over the last few days and
just try and understand how we've got
here because a lot of people myself
included have said that soel Bran's
positions represent a kind of silent
majority in this country and yet we also
have to reconcile that with the fact
that according to some polling 73% of
the public supported her being sacked by
the prime minister so maybe I'm wrong
maybe we're we're wrong to say that she
represents a popular view in this
country uh can you tell us more about
that Suella does represent a majority of
people in this country in terms of the
positions that she holds and the things
that she cares about um she wants to
reduce Mass immigration she thinks
multiculturalism as a policy is broken
she wants to deport foreign Nationals
who glorify terrorism as you discussed
with Douglas Murray on your your recent
show she's she says the institutions are
ideologically biased they're skewed
towards liberal Progressive causes and
she thinks that the government um our
prevailing culture is no longer
prioritizing the majority that it's
become obsessed with an identity white
politics now on all of those issues and
I've pulled them and I've written about
it on on substack I've written about it
on Twitter um those are majority
positions not 51% there's 60 to
75% why you're seeing numbers in terms
ofish was right to dump Suella well
those are all voter numbers they're not
conservative party voters they're not
levers if you look at the conservative
party electorate only a minority of them
think Rishi suak was right to dump sella
braan and while we're here only a very
small minority of them think he was
right to bring back David Cameron I mean
you've got you've got the change
candidate bringing back the conservative
party leader from 2005 to 2016 so the
strategy is all over the place but sella
speaks for a a majority of this country
who are looking at the conservative
party many people watching this show
looking at the labor party too and
realizing what we are now living through
is a restoration of an elite liberal
consensus which will tolerate No dissent
no questioning of that consensus and
what worries me more than anything about
what we've witnessed in recent days it's
another example of a radical alternative
voice being purged from politics think
about what we've seen Boris Johnson got
Liz truss Gone soel braan Gone to that
we might also say Jeremy Corbin and the
radical left gone um radical dissenting
voices people who question the social
and economic consensus in this country
are being purged from politics and and
the Public Square that makes me nervous
that makes me very worried about where
we're going as a society because I don't
think we're even able to tolerate
dissent anymore um and that is why I'm
almost hoping that this Civil War Within
the conservative party actually leads to
much longer term structural change in
British politics and we'll come back and
talk about that Matt do you think and
there are some people who will say this
my father in particular who's a
conservative voter that she swed the
seeds of her own demise with some of the
language and the rhetoric that she used
it was unnecessarily inflammatory is
what social conservatives and my
father's ilk would say I think that's
true and I think there's a criticism of
sella which would say at times she
wasn't necessarily
um behaving in a way that was um what
you would expect for somebody in high
office um sella in reply would say that
she was there with a specific brief a
specific mandate and that as her
resignation letter makes clear she made
a deal with Richie sunak that involved
delivering on a number of things that
were in the 2019 Manifesto lowering
migration um strengthening the country's
borders um dealing with the um illegal
migrants in the small boats and so on
and that the rest of the cabinet
including the Prime Minister
consistently failed to deliver on those
promises so sella would say it was her
duty to speak out in the way that she
did and it was her duty to represent
those voters who went with the
conservatives in 29 and you know what
and I know I read your subs too on this
and we we ended up writing similar
things I think she's right actually and
I think
sella really understands where the a
voter is on these issues and I think
many people as you will know on this
show are looking at the institutions the
BBC the universities the creative
Industries the cultural institutions and
they are now seeing a consensus on the
erosion of sex-based Rights support from
Mass migration um the imposition of woke
ideology in schools in in the cultural
institutions the Galleries and museums a
cynicism of who we are of our history of
our identity and they're just saying you
know what this is this is a consensus
that speaks to no more than 20% of the
country no more than 20% of Britain are
strongly and significantly liberal
that's it 20% so 80% are out there
saying Y what on Earth is this what is
this consensus who wants this consensus
and of course the answer is the elite
want this consensus and soeller I think
violated that and we can see what
happens when you violate that and but
also as well there was when she wrote
that article there were people who were
saying that that was a violation that
was her stepping out of that was her
stepping out of line that was her
directly challenging the authority of
the conservative party can you see why
if you put yourself in Richie Sho shoes
she made her position untenable yeah
sure she violated the um uh assumption
the unwritten well the formal agreement
that the police and and the government
should be independent and and she waited
into that um
look that piece also made a number of
good substantive points why is it that
Co lockdown protesters were treated so
badly relative to Black lives matter
demonstrators why is it that visibly
pramas supporters were given a free pass
while farri right goons and thugs were
rounded up and and treated the way they
were there there is an imbalance or at
least there is a widespread perception
of an imbalance when police officers are
taking the knee to express solidarity
with BLM or as we saw last weekend
having photographs taken with children
dressed up as terrorists islamist
terrorists the police also have a duty
to remain politically impartial as to
our schools by the way um and what I
think many voters are sick of is looking
at these institutions and seeing an
ideological bias at work and sella
called that out and
um you know I understand the criticism
that you know she had a responsibility
to to maintain the independence of the
police and so on but we should still be
able to have a national debate about the
things we are actually seeing on the
streets on social media and that's what
worries me Matt is that what we have now
is to boo subjects when before these
subjects were in the mainstream of
politics immigration the fact that if
you come out and say we need to stop the
boats that is then equated with a nent
Nazi Party by one of our most prominent
sports broadcasters is rable
well I think the idea that the
conservative party is a farri party is
amus amusing when you consider that the
conservative party is the most
pro-immigration party we've ever had in
British Politics the conservative party
has presided over the biggest increase
in both legal and illegal immigration
that Britain has ever seen full stop y
right net migration was 300,000 when
David Cameron came in in 2010 it's
64,000 as we talk in November 2023 the
new figures will come out in the next
week and it will go even higher so the
idea that the conservative party is far
right is is a joke but your point is a
very important one what we're witnessing
is the expansion of social norms so so
racism transphobia homophobia hate you
notice everyone had a problem with hate
March but not hate crime so the social
norms get expanded and now why does that
happen it happens because um people want
to silence and stigmatize views that
undermine or challenge the dominant
status quo that challenge the Zeitgeist
that challenge the consensus
among a more socially culturally liberal
Elite and as you made you made this
point I think this week Constantin that
um you look at the reaction to
trigonometry I think for the first time
really in recent history those
institutions or Legacy institutions are
actually realizing that they cannot
continue with that game because vot
voters citizens are going to leave
they're going to explore other forums
they're going to explore other
institutions other avenues and that you
can see that happening Radio 4 today I
have to listen to it every morning for
work it drives me crazy Radio 4 today
has lost two two and a half million
listeners since brexit public trust in
the BBC is collapsing trust in BBC
journalists telling the truth has
declined sharply over the last 20 years
and I think voters are just realizing
that the way in which we have these
conversations for example the pro
Palestine protests getting sort of
sidetracked into a debate about Tommy
Robinson well actually the real debate
there what should have been on the front
pages after the after Remembrance Day
were people dressed up as Hamas
terrorists that should have been on the
front page of every National newspaper
Tommy Robinson relative to radical
islamism I'm I'm sorry Tommy Robinson is
nowhere near as much of a threat as
radical pramas islamism um in Western
democracies that is a major major threat
the far right is a problem I used to
work on the far right I it's a problem
but what we are talking about is a
revolutionary existential challenge to
our way of life uh radical islamists
want to completely overthrow the
institutions and our society much like
the woke left so we're seeing the toxic
combination of the two feeding off one
another and somewhere along the way we
lost our perspective and we lost our
sense of what's important um and what
should be prioritized and I think we saw
that in recent weeks actually we should
probably clarify Matt that when you say
that you used to work on the far right
what you mean is when you were an
academic you were resar
right I we should just clarify that I
wasn't Marching In the Streets you were
not marching in the streets but you do
like a good tear up every now and again
so uh one of the things you touched on
that I want to come back to the Civil
War and the conservative party in the
future of the country in the second but
one of the things you touched on that is
the media and uh I have to be honest and
this may sound radical but over the last
few days that Meme that I keep seeing
online which is no matter how much you
hate the media you don't hate them
enough that has really come to the for
because because my view is you know what
is the definition of far right to me the
definition of far right is people who
are sexist and intolerant of other
ethnic and religious groups homophobic
think women are second class citizens
and should be kept in the home Etc and
people who incite and use violence in
the streets and from that definition
we've had the far right on the streets
of Britain for 5 weeks every weekend and
the police have done absolutely nothing
about it and the moment as you say that
a few
football Hooligans come out and they
throw some bottles that is wrong they
shouldn't be doing that and anyone who
breaks the law should be condemned for
it and the police should deal with them
but you can see a the double standards
in the way that they're policed and much
more much more than that the double
standards in the way that it's covered
in the media where they say nothing
about people saying death to all the
Jews Hitler knew what to do with the
Jews all of these incidents which are as
marginal as the Tommy Robinson thing is
to to the entire feeling in country
about it but they don't get the
attention at all what happens instead is
they just focus on that one incident
because it feeds into the narrative that
they want to push and I think the the
country's had enough of it I think
that's right um I wrote last week about
the interplay between the the rise of of
a very aggressive uh radical islamism
and the rise of of the woke left and why
the interaction of the two is so
important and we we have lost sight of
the the scale of that threat I mean what
is it that the the wot left and radical
islamist have in common um both are
illiberal um they have no interest in
individual rights and individual liberty
um both are revolutionary they seek a
complete overthrow of the existing
system and institutions um both are
cynical if not hostile towards Western
ways of life they view US fundamentally
as racist um as uh Prejudice towards um
minorities both cling to a very um crude
binary view of who we are there are are
believers or there are non-believers
there are the oppressed there are the
oppressors there is no room for nuance
there is no room for pluralism there is
no room um for complexity in society
both are um very organized around
rituals um is in radical islamists it is
it is prayer it is albar it is shouting
all of these slogans for the woke it is
taking the knee it is saying you know no
justice no peace etc etc um and so what
you're seeing I think is is as the the
culture left is taking control of
Institutions is kind of pushing in this
identitarian view of the world where
there are oppressors and the oppressed
it's basically opening the door for
radical islamism it's allowing radical
islamism to to to thrive in this model
of multiculturalism which is broken and
that's what sella said sella said look
the issue is not Multicultural societies
right I mean I was amazed that serious
National columnist didn't understand
this really yeah well she was saying
there is no problem with mul cultural
societies per se but there is a problem
with
multiculturalism yes which prioritizes
group difference over commonality and
that is what's enabled um radical
islamists and terrorist sympathizers to
flourish in communities up and down
Britain in highly segregated communities
and sella was absolutely right in saying
if you want to respond seriously to the
challenges that we face as a country we
are going to have to dramatically reduce
immigration legal immigration we're
going to have to leave any institution
or judicial convention that doesn't
allow us to control our own National
borders we're going to have to have a
new policy of integration which ensures
that no child uh family can grow up in a
highly segregated Community with no
interaction with wider British society
and we're going to have to get a hell of
a lot tougher when it comes to the rule
of law and deporting foreign Nationals
who glorify terrorism and I know you've
talked about this already I pulled that
76% of Voters said yeah if you're in the
streets of Britain and you're a foreign
National and you're glorifying Hamas or
you're glorifying is you should leave
Britain we don't want you here you
should get out of the national community
and so the era of us being tolerant of
people who do not tolerate our way of
life is over and I think it should come
to an end as quickly as possible and
sella represents that I think you say
it's over Matt and I certainly know that
for a lot of people the last few weeks
have been eye openening to be sure and I
think I myself I'm look I've always
every day I'm Fielding ACC accusations I
inverted commas of being conservative
and I'm still not conservative but if
the if if this is if this is the choice
I know which side I'm going to play on
irrespective of what my overall beliefs
about liberalization of drugs and
whatever is you see what I'm saying so
for a lot of people it's an eye-
openening moment however you say that
moment that world is over the next next
election is going to be a labor
Landslide isn't it it will be a labor
Landslide but what I mean is in terms of
The Wider Zeitgeist in terms of the
public mood you cannot you cannot come
out of the last few weeks thinking
immigration and multiculturalism has
been good for Britain has been an
unalloyed success story it is now
visible to everybody we have a major
problem within our communities in
Britain we have people homegrown who are
out on the streets calling for the
murder and the rape of Jews now of
course you might say well we saw that
after 911 we saw it after 77 I think it
has become a much bigger problem now
it's on a different scale than what it
was 20 years ago and the other thing I
would just say is there is a widespread
sense out there in the country many
viewers watching this I think will agree
70% of people now say neither left nor
right represent me MH the space for a
new radical Challenger to this broken
consensus is enormous it will take money
it will take organization and it will
take a charisma itic leader but the
space is bigger than it was in 2013 2014
because voters out there are utterly Fed
Up of this broken status quo between
left and right you can feel it I was in
a focus group last week in Stoke on
Trend voters are crying in a focus group
they're saying no one's got the answers
to cost of living no one's got the
answers to productivity the lack of
productivity nobody's seriously leveling
up nobody's bringing down immigration
nobody's dealing with the small boats
they can't do it anything anymore it's
almost as if our rulers are incapable of
actually bringing about the changes that
voters want to see but okay so I take on
I take on board what you're saying but
that doesn't doesn't that also mean we
need to get rid of first pass the post
then I personally would support
electoral reform I'm I'm I would support
the shift of proportional representation
because I think the majoritarian system
no longer works for the um Myriad of
concerns and groups that we have in in
British Society I would personally
support that and I think so with many
people who are disgruntled with left and
right it's very difficult to upend a big
party in a majoritarian system it's not
impossible happened in Canada in the
early 90s the labor party of course
replac the Liberals it it is it is
possible it's very very difficult but
there's another issue here which you
guys directly tap into which is there's
fixing the politics of this and then
there's fixing the culture of this and I
think the culture the ecosystem that is
emerging to give expression to people
who no longer want to abide by this
Elite consensus is now much bigger than
it was five years ago and is enormous
compared to what it was 10 years ago the
substacks the YouTube shows the uh the
the New Media GB News Talk TV whatever
the landscape is fundamentally different
so the culture is changing and I think
what makes the new Elite the kind of
dominant class so nervous is they can
now sense that they can sense they're
not in control anymore they can sense
things are beginning to to shift so I um
well yeah that's why private I writing
hit pieces about us and all of that all
of that stuff but let's come back to
this idea that the next election will be
a labor Landslide because we all know it
will be especially after the last couple
of days I mean there's there's no way of
rescuing this right for the
conservatives no you you're shaking your
head no I I I I I would give richy Sak a
1% chance two% chance 2% chance
so that means the next five years we've
got a year or so until the next election
mhm could be in January 2025 but
probably not then you've got five four
years of a labor
government and my understanding is part
of sel's move was that that defeat next
year for the conservative party is her
opportunity to be the knight in China
and arm asde well look I tried you
didn't listen to me look what happened
now I'm here let's do the let's be real
conservative now the conservative party
will never allow that to to happen the
conservative parliamentary party and the
donor class will never allow the Tory
party to be reshaped I'm increasingly of
the view that Peter Hitchens was right
all
along we love Peter if if you want to
save Britain we need to basically
destroy the conservative
party now the reason I say that is
because look at swella the fact that she
has attracted so much heat from her own
colleagues tells you all you need to
know about the state of conservatism
here's what we need to do we need to
basically if you care about the country
I would argue we need to
rebuild a new National conservatism
which is very different from what we've
got with the British Tories a national
conservatism would prioritize a number
of things which today's conservative
party simply do not do it would
prioritize dramatic reductions in legal
immigration potentially a 5-year freeze
so we can absorb the migration of the
last 20 years it would prioritize a
robust and radical policy for
integration no more segregation no more
multiculturalism which allows
communities to remain distinct from The
Wider British Community it would focus
on cultivating a story about who we are
the economy should work for the national
Community not globalized offshore
interests it should be fundamentally
about promoting and preserving the
national interest a tough approach on
Law and Order including the deportation
of foreign Nationals who glorify
terrorism or who commit crime um
revitalizing the country's manufacturing
base redistributing power not just
government departments but Power outside
of London and University towns to other
parts of the country having a robust
pro- family policy which is not just
about giving people tax breaks but
encouraging people to have children I
could go on there are about 10 12
principles that should Define National
conservative a national conservatism
which also reaches into sections of the
labor party which Francis you know very
well um and also reaches into the
conservatives but also reaches into the
apathetic masses the none of the above
you say none of these parties actually
represent me anymore now the Republicans
are beginning to understand the
difference between National conservatism
and what we might call Chinos
conservatives in name only right they're
understanding that they're understanding
the potency of that they're also
understanding the need for that if you
want to stand up to China you want to
you want to stand up to Russia you want
to stand up to you know woke ideas and
whatever you need a strong nation state
with strong families and um a robust
economy that works for the national
interest and you want Power concentrated
in the principle of popular sovereignty
in in the people you do not want Power
diluted and transferred to institutions
outside of the nation state or to
institutions which are not directly
accountable to the people which is what
Rwanda is about the only people making
that decision should be people directly
elected by ordinary citizens so what I
would argue is we need a reassertion of
popular sovereignty in British politics
we need a movement for the people which
transcends left and right and whoever
gets there first whoever presses that
button whoever speaks for the masses on
those issues will find themselves being
catapulted to the very Forefront of
British politics and you mentioned the
need for a charismatic leader I put it
to you the the one person that I think
could Unite
that Coalition because he's done it
before he's currently eating kangaroo
balls in Australia whatever is he Nigel
farage is up to is is is that who you
think is the man or do you think it's
time for someone fresh I think Nigel um
would definitely need to be part of that
movement because Nigel um has
consistently been the most impactful but
also underestimated politician of our
time there is something interesting
happening here's one scenario let's say
Niger frage goes in the jungle and and
it isn't a disaster let's say his brand
actually comes out a bit stronger a new
generation understand what he's about
let's say a load of 2019 conservative
MPS from the red wo lose their seats and
they're Milling around they're not sure
what to do I care about the country but
I've lost my seat I understand these red
wallers but why is David Cameron now
back in the cabinet um let's add to that
um you know the the the the ranks of
Reform um the Reform Party maybe the
Social Democratic party the sdp um
influential commentators and columnists
from the from the new media from the
YouTube channels and the substacks and
the the Twitter sphere and the new
magazines and the online platforms
everybody who is basically United in
understanding what's gone wrong and
where we need to go that is the basis
for something serious that is the basis
for something that will attract
funding people energy and will have an
impact and and if you look at all
Western democracies over the last 20
years one of the key stories is that now
is the time for Renegades and radical
Challengers and insurgents who are
willing to take on the dinosaur parties
Emanuel macron Georgia Maloney Donald
Trump Sweden Democrats could go on and
on and on now is the time for new people
to stand up and say we're not going to
do this anymore we're not going to give
another four fiveyear term to a party
that is exactly the same as the other
party if label win the next election
Constantine you know this the consensus
doesn't change High tax big state Mass
immigration low growth high debt nothing
fundamentally changes there is no
radical shaking up of the status quo
yeah but trans people are going to have
more right to make good oh and we'll be
giving government contracts out on the
basis of race and ethnicity with the
racial equality act so what we have is a
more divided woke ified Society along
the lines of America and the things that
make us unique as British having a
unifying story we're proud of our
history we're proud of our identity
we're proud of our values um you know we
we we're proud of free enterprise all of
those things gradually get weakened and
undermined Matt one of the things I'm
worried about and I don't think people
are talking about this enough is that if
labor get in with a significant majority
which I'm not sure they will if they're
honest because every leftwing person
I've ever spoken to is dubious about
starma to put it mildly no one seems
particularly enthused by him yeah I'm
sure they'll all vote for sunak
mate but they might not vote they might
not yeah but my point My worry is this
it's blasphemy laws I can see a labor
government bringing in blasphemy laws I
really can and I find that incredibly
worrying it's already happened we've
already had uh non nonviolent hate
crimes and we've had uh you know you go
on to London Tube you're lectured by
billboard posters about you know hate
speech and hate language um that's by
the way another similarity between the
woke left and radical islamists they're
both very supportive of blasphemy and
they're both very supportive of limiting
free speech and free expression in the
name of their ideological Mission this
is why I've always had a problem with
the cultural left because the first
thing to go in their project is free
speech and free expression it's the F
they will sacrifice free speech on the
altar of social justice every time they
will cancel they will silence they will
Purge every time and um that's why this
movement is a liberal and it's you know
when we first started talking about the
woke you remember everyone would say
this thing doesn't exist this thing is
ridiculous now look at the books
recently right Francis fukiyama identity
Yasha monk the identity trap Susan nean
woke has not left there is now an
acceptance on the center left that they
have a major problem it took them 10
years to get there right many of us were
there a lot earlier but even the left
now understand actually this thing that
we've allowed to uh kind of get out the
bottle is now destroying uh wider
Society it just took them too late and I
I have to say I'm with I'm with the
national conservatives on this because
the only thing that is capable of
standing up and meeting these threats
from wokeism from radical islamism will
ultimately be National conservatism it's
the only thing that is strong enough
liberalism liberal parties Centrist ads
are not strong enough to deal with this
threat they don't have the unifying
story they don't have the appeals to
group belonging they don't have the um
the kind of anchor in in our history in
our identity they're too um they're too
fluid um they're not robust they're not
rigorous and I think that's why if the
conservatives are smart they will
reinvent around National conservative
principles if they're not smart they
will rally behind somebody like Penny
Moran and they will say the future is
David Cameron 2.0 and that would be a
big problem well we've got David Cameron
1.0 moment so I mean this is the other
thing right Vish presents himself as
change candidate and then brings back
David no one thinks he a change candid I
I just don't understand I don't
understand the politics behind it at all
I don't think he understands the
politics behind it I don't think I don't
think there is anybody left Center or on
the right apart from Ian Dale who
thought this was a good idea bless him
when Ian says something's good you you
you know it's not we love Ian is a
friend but on this one yeah we don't
agree but why why is it that when we I
was in Manchester for the Conservative
Party Conference um and richy cak speech
the three the top three things voters
want to talk about today cost of living
crisis state of the NHS immigration
those are the three priorities Rishi
sunak talked about banning smoking
reforming a levels and stopping a
high-speed train line I mean they're
completely different conversations
utterly different and I think sometimes
when you get people as you know in sw1
and politics they're very clever people
and they're bright but sometimes they're
too clever and they overthink things to
such an extent that they leave everybody
else wondering what on Earth this
project is really all about and I think
I know the people around Richi Sun I've
got a lot of respect for them but I
think privately they've now concluded
that they've got a year and they're just
going to do what they're personally
interested in doing so they're going to
do the smoking ban they're going to do
the the a level stuff and they're not
really that bothered about winning the
next election I think they're just now
focusing on pet projects really I think
so and I think you know David Cameron's
appointment jobs for the boys put him in
the House of Lords you rub my back I'll
rub yours I don't think this is a party
as Tim Stanley said a journalist who I
respect a lot former guest of the show
he said this party is
philosophically non-existent I mean it
it has no coherent ideology anymore it
is simply about you know jobs for the
boys Patrician liberalism let's just
keep the establishment happy and
basically F everybody else
and I think that's unfortunately what we
can see from a prime minister who we
should remember doesn't have a
democratic mandate I mean Rishi does not
have a mandate from voters right um and
that's why I think the defeat will be
particularly bruising but you say that
and look I agree with you on the
majority of it but if you think about a
bruising defeat think about Labor in
2019 they came up against Johnson now we
can have all the criticisms in the world
about Johnson but he was fantastic
campaigner he was charismatic he was
funny he had a message when we look at
the destruction of the conservative
party I think it was in 92 not '92 90
yeah with Blair Blair was one of the
best politicians formidable of whatever
gener
Generations starma no terrible but he's
doing what he needs to do to win the
election opposition parties don't win
elections governments lose elections
that's the key principle Boris Johnson
while we're at it was good but he was he
was not a conservative Boris Johnson was
a Bohemian liberal he was not a
conservative we've not really had a
serious conservative leader for a long
time um Kia starm his net ratings are
okay he's on plus 10 rishy sunak
minus5 Prince Andrew's minus 60 that
gives you a kind of gives you a Rel
Benchmark um starm is doing what he
needs to do now the question is what
happens when he wins here's here's a few
here are a few predictions number one
labor break their Manifesto pledges they
have to taxes are going to go up they
can't afford Public Services they can't
afford the all the things we need to pay
for without raising taxes here's one
stat keep in mind no one talks about
this in Frontline
politics guess how much we are spending
every month servicing our national debt
on our country's credit card not not
paying off the debt just paying the
interest guess how how much we're paying
every
month I have no idea 13 billion every
month on national debt okay now what
could you do with 13 billion you could
do a lot right so Labor's pledge to
scrap non-don benefits great that raises
three billion we're paying 13 billion a
month on our national debt so no one's
talking about how to reduce national
debt so when labor come in they're going
to have no real room for maneuver on
fiscal policy on on the economy they're
going to have still the worst living
standards for 50 years they're going to
have immigration probably at somewhere
between 600 and
800,000 we're going to have a housing
crisis which is going to escalate
dramatically we built 180,000 homes last
year we need to build 600,000 every year
just to keep up with migration okay buil
180,000 we're going to need to build
600,000 every year just to keep up with
migration not to mention then we've got
no serious growth strategy we've got no
serious strategy for boosting
productivity we're not talking about
integration and cohesion we're going to
see dramatic population shifts and much
of the Migration by the way is low skill
migration from subsaharan Africa which
is a net cost to the economy it is not
adding to our economy it is taking away
from our economy um before we get into
private rental um rates going up before
we get into school places before we get
into the NHS and as we know Robert Punam
and others have shown this High highly
diverse
societies have lower levels of trust and
lower levels of support for welfare so
if you look at where Britain is going
over the next 20 30 40 years with
parties that seem incapable of even
discussing these issues I'm very very
skeptical of where we're going I'm I'm
actually quite nervous about where we're
going as a society because you cannot
sustain this pace of change and churn
without a serious political response
that is going to manage it and it
doesn't seem to be any attempt to manage
this on any serious level well Matt
while we on that black pill
moment you mentioned Peter Hitchens and
Peter Hitchens when asked on question
time I think 15 or 20 years ago he was
pressed by uh the host at the time David
dimbleby I think on on what people
should do about this and his advice was
immigrate leave and you laugh and I I
have to say I'm not that at all because
I speak to my Jewish friends in London
everyone who has the ability to leave is
thinking of leaving and
frankly I don't blame them I also don't
blame people who are aspirational driven
talented who are business people who are
creative who see um a bright future for
themselves I don't blame them looking
around at what you are projecting which
is no offense to you you're very
talented what you do but it's it's a
statement of the bleeding obvious at
this point that the country is not going
in the right
direction and why why should people stay
why should people stay well I my
daughters two um for the first time in
my life I'm I think I I'm thinking of
leaving the country I don't think
Britain in many respects is a serious
country anymore I think our national
conversation has sharply deteriorated
the quality of our national conversation
over the last 20 years the ruling class
the inability to discuss the serious
issues the short termism in the media um
the refusal to entertain any challenge
to the prevailing ideas or the Orthodoxy
the stifling of free speech the
imposition of political correctness the
politicization of our
institutions the blatant bias that we
can see in schools universities policing
um and also I think what worries me most
is the general
disinterest in preserving and passing on
who we are that's the thing that gets me
the most it's almost like um Roger
scrutin used to talk about the politics
of repudiation the culture of
repudiation um we're more interested now
in repudiating than respecting our
shared history our shared identity and
our culture um there were very few
glimmers of of hope you know there are
some the campaign to defend women's
sex-based rights I think is scoring real
victories you can see that in Labor's
backt tracking and K stas changes
Scotland was interesting the gender
recognition Reform Bill being
overturned um but the but but the
victories are few and far between amid
all of that between all of that is the
Relentless onslaught of this cultural
revolution which is what we're living in
it is a cultural revolution being
imposed by the institutions on on
everybody else so I am thinking of um
for the first time in my life leaving
the country and as I said to you earlier
on sometimes you realize that Peter
Hitchens was right all along well this
is an argument that will make Peter
obviously very happy we talked about I
don't think there's anything that would
make Peter happy that would that would I
think that would uh but I think the the
interesting thing perhaps to explore is
we we H we interviewed Neil Ferguson the
historian
um and that episode's going out this
Sunday I think from memory and we put
all of this to him and he said well look
the one thing that we maybe could look
at for inspiration is the 1970s when
Israel had just been attacked in the Yum
kipor War uh the state of the economy
and the state of the country in the UK
was probably even worse than it is now
can we look to that for inspiration M or
were the circumstances different I'm not
convinced by that for a couple of
reasons the one is how did the 70s end
with the arrival of radical leaders
willing to take on the
consensus we are no longer capable of
tolerating leaders who challenge the
consensus who is the next Margaret
Thatcher well they'll be silenced and
shut down in five minutes It'll be very
difficult as Liz truss and Boris Johnson
showed whatever you think of them as
their experiment showed we cannot
tolerate descent or a change of course
even brexit was a sort of national
trauma a kind of
a breakdown in our in our colle the
other thing about the 70s just briefly
just before you do the other thing about
70s is the dominant issues in the 70s
were economic and today culture matters
as much as the economy and so the
dividing lines in our society are much
more complex in many regards as they
than they were in the 70s and that's
what makes it so difficult to actually
find a way through there someone to put
it we're not one people anymore no and
we don't have a unifying story anymore
there is no no sense of uh uh there's
not even a willingness you know if you
go back and you read say who are we by
by um by Samuel Huntington which is a
good book on American national identity
you know and he argues that that
essentially the the the the national
unifying story in America was undermined
by by large scale migration and by the
rise of an elite class that that no
longer believed and invested in the
nation um and in many respects we are
now seeing that play out here a sort of
a tendency to
to look down on who we are and and to
expose a national Community to such
change at such a pace that everybody is
left feeling bewildered not really sure
who they are what they think the counter
argument I was going to put to you was
the possibility of you get a labor
Landslide or certainly a labor win at
least as you made a good point that it
might not be a
landslide um things don't get better
things get worse which they certainly
will they will and then at that point
the public have just had enough and
there is actually the room for achel
like figure to come to come out and not
be rejected by the public at least but
that that's premised on the notion that
our political parties would allow that
to happen and the problem we have is
both left and right were products of the
Industrial Revolution they were built
100 years ago so the two main political
parties that we have were were built for
another era what what I think we need is
the creation of new vessels of new
vehicles and surrounding that a new
culture you know a new prevailing
culture which is much more in tune with
ordinary people and I think that that is
one of the things we need to do um we
need to reform the institutions we need
to make them more representative of a
wide array of voices the BBC as I say
the cultural
institutions with the other thing by the
way a national conservative a movement
would do is take on institutions which
are taxpayer funded but do not represent
the interest of the nation universities
would be one example BBC would be
another you know we have to start
drawing lines in the sand we have to
start saying these are the things that
made us who we are and this is what
we're going to defend and this is what
we're going to promote I mean Faith
schools would be another example I don't
think personally we should have faith
schools now I think we need to even
Catholic schools and Christian Schools
well I I think some Faith schools I
think we should be we should be open to
but I think we need to start
really assertively going drawing some
lines in the sand about what our
civilization is what our values are and
how we're going to defend those values
and conservatives have completely given
up on that argument at arkc recently one
of the refreshing things at the ark
conference which I think Constantine
mentioned in his speech you know these
cultural issues which are so important
to people women's sex-based rights the
rights of children our identity our
history our culture our values all those
things what the left does now and I
would say also many people on the right
what they do now is they package all of
that up and they say well this is
culture Wars It's toxic socially
unacceptable don't talk about that it's
low status and so conservatives have
allowed the foundations of our
civilization to be completely
discredited taken off the table of
political debate so if you say I think
kids should be taught what Britain got
right not what Britain got wrong or
women sex-based rights should be
protected and enshrined in law and
defended at every turn or you know we
should have a radically different
approach to migration because over time
Mass migration uncontrolled migration
dilutes who we are um all of those
things should be on the table up for
discussion and in a very short space of
time they've been taken off the table
and that I think is why so many voters
feel very anxious for a group of MPS
recently who will remain nameless but
they are very influential within the
conservative party they asked me to do
some polling they said what are the
issues that voters feel most concerned
about but not represented on the top
three immigration's out of control I
don't like political correctness I want
to be able to preserve and promote
Britain's distinctive identity from
globalization from Universal liberalism
those three things right very simple
things we could do all of those things
we could do them tomorrow we could have
policies with a movement that delivered
on all those things why isn't the
conservative party doing that I put it
to you Matt that the problem actually is
the politicians and it's because a lot
of them are career politicians they've
never had a proper job they've just gone
straight A lot of them have gone
straight from University to become
political advisers assistants to MPS
blah blah blah they are West they are
people of Westminster they've never had
a real job they've never had to they've
never had to graft they've never
experienced a lot of the struggles of
what Ordinary People do and these are
the people on the left as well not just
on the right so what we've got is an
entire strata of people who don't
understand the people they're ruling or
the people they they've been essentially
they've been been asked to govern
because they've never been one of them I
agree the the the biggest single tribe
in Westminster are careerist people who
have only ever spent their lives in
politics there have never been more
University graduates in the House of
Commons as there are today the labor
party has more University graduates than
the conservative party on the green
benches so everything has become
ideologically uniform everything has
become homogeneous um some friends of
mine in Academia they did a survey of
MPS on the right and the left and they
found that both conservative and labor
MPS lean much further to the cultural
left than the average voter so when
voters are looking at politic at
Westminster saying you know why don't
they just do the Randa scheme why don't
they just stop the boats why don't they
stop the woke why don't they do XYZ
because our MPS don't really have any
interest in doing that they are no
longer representative of the country
that surrounds them so what do you need
to do you need to build a movement that
is representative of the of the uh
country that is actually speaking on
behalf of a forgotten majority and I
think that is the next step look we can
change the culture we can build an
ecosystem but but there comes a point
where you have to also translate culture
into action you have to translate
culture into political action otherwise
it is ultimately meaningless if you
don't have your hands on the levers of
power if you cannot influence the
decisions that are affecting our daily
lives right you're not in the end going
to change anything and I think that is
the next phase of this build an
ecosystem convert it into political
action there are people I'm sure who are
big fans of the STP I always vote for
the SCP because they have the best
policies and the ones that I believe in
people of Reform who will be going well
what about us Matt we've been doing this
we've been at the Forefront of this why
can't people come to us well if you look
at there's a literature on how to build
a party and break through and it
suggests certain things are very
important one is money you need a lot of
money secondly you need a charismatic
leader who can genuinely cut through
really connect third you need a
laser-like focus on a single issue which
really matters to a large majority of
people I mean I've had these
conversations with reform people and sdp
people I think they're all good people
by the way I think they care about the
country um and I've got a lot of time
for all of them but I think probably
given the the scale of the problems
facing Britain we are I think rapidly
approaching a point where everybody is
going to have to start to work together
uh and going to have to start to
prioritize the issues that they really
care about to be blunt Net Zero um tax
those sorts of issues yes they're
important but but the real pressing
issues for people are not those issues
the real pressing issues for people now
is about how the fabric of our country
is changing and how to slow that down
and change it and uh that is going to
mean Shifting the Overton window
dragging the Overton window into a very
different place you know expanding it um
and and beginning to put policies on the
table which are completely different
from the policies that are being offered
by left and right and Matt is there a
potential I mean we've obviously talked
about the difficulties with uh creating
some sort of New Movement within a
two-party system like the one that we
have we have seen while brexit I don't
think has delivered many of the things
that people hoped it would it
nonetheless gave voice to the hidden
concerns of many many people in the
country is there room for some sort of
of I don't know referendum on illegal
immigration or something along those
lines where uh like you said it's a
single issue that many people feel very
strongly about that can uh Galvanize
people into that uh is there a mechanism
to do that is that something that would
be advisable even well if you look at
Nigel farage and the UK independence
party they started the brexit journey by
offering a referendum on EU membership
or calling for a referendum um that's
done and by the way I'm not as
apologetic about brexit as as as as you
you are and many people in the debate
are I actually think on balance I still
think brexit now I didn't campaign for
brexit but I think now that it's
happened it's a good thing because we
can exert much greater control over a
wide array of issues what's happened is
a political class have chosen not to use
that power in a way that was consistent
with brexit voters so they chose to
liberalize migration not change it etc
etc they chose to deregulate financial
services not not rev ize manufacturing
and heavy industry and we can go on and
on about those things I still think
brexit was the right call but um in
terms of in terms of um moving forward
and trying to get to a place where um we
can we can build something different you
know
fundamentally we have to build a
political economy that is no longer
dependent upon importing cheap migrant
workers from from abroad where the
salary thresholds are as low as £2,000
23,000 um and we have to get away from
this addiction to looking outside of
Britain for the answers um to our
problems and um our political class I
think is increasingly incapable of doing
that all of the interesting political
ideas in the world right now are in
America or Europe I can't think of a
single interesting idea that's coming
out of British politics at the moment I
genuinely cannot I mean if you think
about Blair whatever you think about
Blair he actually had some interesting
ideas about you know public service
reform and all these sorts of things but
at the moment um I can't think of a
single interesting idea that's coming
out of British politics from this
political class um and that again you
know worries me do is there a worry and
we're going to go a little bit black
pill again you look at this and you
think well this is fertile breeding
ground for the far right surely but we
don't we're not we are not a country
that would support a farri political
party and the way in which that is used
to constrain debate
is increasing it's very problematic you
know the idea that the conservative
party is a farri party oh that's moronic
it's ridiculous and the idea that we
have generations of kids being brought
up to think that sella braan is somehow
comparable to Joseph G Geral or like you
know Adolf Hitler is ridiculous and it's
and it's a reflection both of the the
quality of education and the quality of
our of our cultural class right the
people who dominate the the debate like
Gary ler and Alistar Campbell I mean
most of those people I would describe to
be frank as morons I don't think they
really understand what they're talking
about or if they do they're just doing
it through a sense of you know virtue
signaling and moral righteousness that
that's not my so the far right for the
far right to prosper what do you need
yeah suspicion of democracy or at least
appetite for for an anti-democratic
alternative you need to have public
support for a revolutionary movement
something that would tear down
institutions tear down the system
something that's openly racist that says
you know actually if you're black
British black Chinese black Indian
you're not really British you've got to
be white to be to be British um
something that's uh something that is
anti-Semitic something that probably
offers a conspiratorial view of the
world and these are utterly Fringe views
in British Society 95% of Brits in the
ipsos Mori data say you do not have to
be white to be British support for
democracy is still very strong even if
voters were prefer
a more direct conception of democracy
right give more voice to the people a
little bit less to the Elites in
Westminster um there is very little
appetite for revolutionary change in
Britain we have a Civic culture right we
we respect moderation we respect
difference we respect pluralism but
that's why Brits are so nervous because
they can feel the woke left and the
radical islamist closing that down the
Civic culture so so the British defense
of this is actually utterly different
from the far right that's why the far
right is nowhere I mean tomby Robinson
is is a fringe figure 80 people on White
Hall is is not a a serious national
movement it is fringe which is good we
should celebrate that but but that is
not to say we we do not need a new
political movement which campaigns on
some issues like migration like
political correctness like the collapse
of our um the quality of our
representative democracy um they're
different things I don't personally fear
the far right in Britain um but I do
fear what is going to happen if we don't
actually start to change our politics
Matt you're a busy guy so we're not
going to have time for questions from
our audience however uh you guys should
know that we took all the locals
questions those of you who support some
locals thank you so much we took the
questions you put in there and we use
them to guide the interview Matt before
we let you go uh to fulfill your busy
schedule as ever what's the one thing
that we forgot to mention or haven't
been talking about in the course of this
conversation what what are saying I
would say there's a there's a silver
lining which is the union is safe the
United Kingdom is I think generally safe
I think the reassertion of Labor in
Scotland the collapse of the
conservative party in the aftermath of
the next election we will not be talking
about the breakup of the United Kingdom
and I think that is one good thing that
we can we can focus on well there you go
the UK is going to be terrible but it's
going to stay together
yeah like a
marriage all right guys thank you so
much for watching uh thank you for
supporting show make sure you head on
over and subscribe to Matt substack
which is very good I read it all the
time I quoted him in my substack today
so make sure you go and check that out
Matt thank you for being on the show
thank you for having me guys and we will
see you very soon guys take care have
yourselves a good evening afternoon or
morning wherever it
is